right let's go guys we're going to play
your vehicles let's do it anyone with me
so militate i'm driving a tank me too I
still have no we're goin 40 we got a guy
we got a guy on the hill here I'm gonna
push see got one please go nice right
come on going see you smart this idea
get the guy there you go guys get him in
the horse all right side that's a
concert no I'm only I'm gone you're
right i see take it right now nice one
guys right let's move out be me be go
forth am just so now i'm in you i might
your universal like 360 gun okay I'm
like okay you've got a way to do a 360
on that there's a light tanks fair
sitting here hello I report plane coming
in where's that light things back I just
jumped out of it Oh plane crash did it
crash I'm trying to go through i am
getting out of the vehicle right we're
still on be there's still a couple of
there's a couple of enemies around the
back here all right round the back i got
it oh and body and they would know who
I'd be low five years loads by D let's
go take dude they got a tank as well
blow your word we're taking out for
bears identity playing playing banging
comic
I have a plane I'm gonna go follow I'm
gonna wait for that amount of time she's
ones on how is this not killing this guy
still at the guy we do you're coming
around the big long there we go it's got
the guy on d occasion I don't have a
vehicle on the bomber long as down
bother staff see looks fairly unguarded
I've got this a far superior oh why me
guys see that oh I got killed off the
back got there with some good driving
quite a few people on see oh ok i'll
pick it out yeah there's a heavy tone
every tank on show all we did every time
yeah my dragon we don't have a gun we've
got there too quick trying out ladies on
to hell ride bombing run going all I
managed to sneak away from the heavy
tank just like the way you look at where
boys and it's on see now four of the top
40 thats hanging down with dynamite I'm
a bummer Oh Oh guys that way that was a
pretty awesome wrap yeah mondi I'm on
the front of the bomber now fantastic
you know I don't put there i'ma do duty
I'm trying
got an acting on my horse ones on the
roof on the roof and you have for the
building will Obama nice we got we're
getting the identity yeah good all that
body shop irri top of the behind Ryan um
what is going on for playing opposite
opposite opposite defender the vanity I
gotta be here that's from the cannon yet
wait you might want to go it's my
favorite yeah oh I see apologize plan it
was a summer war
hey on then
all right yeah I can see you know me I
may feel kind of somebody on the sable
bit that's good
I'm gonna drive to amaze objective that
we need to get the Turks away from the
train track because otherwise the trains
just knew obliterate the check the tanks
I'm coming in now let me get my home go
get the train once yeah why here we go
one membranes likes trains got less than
half health I just wanted to thank
tarick's disabled on the front of the
train now no no no oh no all right go me
to repair if you don't hit me don't have
raised and trained got it no dad right
I've got enough health and going again I
thought the train was a thief some
reason but a light tent do any damage to
the truth yeah how much uh fair effect i
think it's 22 / shell yeah we're like
you get a strain really isn't in the
last very I tagged by to myself i blue
myself it's nearly a quarter health now
god never play another number one money
it's got a sausage well towards the left
and caller help now coming towards the
light thing will just slow down killer
see they're highly by a strain
restraints knocking oh my god who's
getting hit with the VA a gun holy crap
that literally went down so quick I did
quite a bit of damage to it though yeah
yes no no there's a bomber it's coming
over the top oh oh gotta like I mean
this train having an epic battle of it
oh oh oh it's got like 5 i'll check out
a massive junk myself or the tank good
evening group it's like nothing turn a a
gun here he comes grenade attack Oh to
the dads and sensitive that I know I'm
gonna sport oh gosh your tree and you
hit one of those bombs it's going to go
and drop drop drop drop adios shake it
yes that's very nice that's fantastic so
I can tell you now like the planks
you're gonna flank the guy who's killing
me kind of fame see ya there is i'll put
Adam in the back how are they not dying
they're literally like
all right give me a flag and I'll going
to need to know need to move about this
place is IG yeah yeah I'm running
straight into them this is such a stupid
idea writing down about go up behind you
yeah I got one we get you out of it so I
finished him off yesterday you all in
you all on the ground onion ya see that
commercials just lack of vehicles sniper
in their eyes now Eddie nice that'd be
cool cool let's go got one then all the
way back up now mercy I got that guy
taken aback when taking it back if I
fighting behind your dental yeah I see
him I see him he kills boy destroyed
yeah he was fight anybody my sympathy
him he's the nice that was so good that
was awesome right let's see if we can
take one hour left on our left huawei oh
yeah I feel like saying when it got a
nice awesome let's see if we can take be
all right guy running out at B now going
after that is that John yep we about get
absolutely wrecked one of our points
guys a lot more points I'm just spotting
people coming in and I said I see that
one you're looking at I'm about to drop
bombs on the plane well running a gun on
the plane hiding behind the fielder
Thermal he's on the field gun damn it
and the heavy tank is gonna kill me
ditchin go survival knife give me that
damn in bed fiber yeah 3 do win it oh no
I'm kabir without energy Oh guys I think
we want it we've worse yeah I'm really
impressed with what they've achieved so
far we're working really really well as
a squad together and that's probably the
most important thing regardless of what
their skill level is being able to work
with someone else is the most important
thing because if you're talking to
somebody maybe they can help you with
something that you're not not not that
good at and in battlefield that is so
important because you've got a defined
role your friend's got a different
define role if you work together most of
the time you can achieve the goal that
you want I think come that live stream I
don't think we're going to have a
problem we're coming up against public
players and yes there's some really good
players out there but we've got the
squad play nailed down there they've all
got their roles they all know what
they're supposed to do as long as we
work as a team the public just don't
stand a chance I think they'll be
absolutely fine when they come to the
live stream
play it first with EA access